So stepping up the complexity a tiny bit here, we'll talk about creating masked materials
with some nodes. So we want to cover the process of how you might create a masked material.
We'll talk about using minus nodes and clamps, and we'll also use the lerp node to linear
interpolate between two different channels of the material that we want. We can talk
about masking textures for materials using one texture, and we'll also talk about using
the RBG RGB channels to almost get a more performant texture based on a specific channel
rather than the overall texture. So let's jump into this. So we've got the process.
There are two ways that can be achieved when we're talking about masked materials. So with
an outside alpha embedded in a texture, or you can do it in a standalone texture that
has an alpha data plugged into opacity. You can also do this through the color channels,
which we were talking about with the RGB material setup. So when you create a texture
sample, you'll have an alpha pin on the texture sample, which is the main output, and then
it's the RGB, and then you've got an A. So anything imported with some kind of opacity,
a 32 bit alpha channel, you can use that alpha to plug into one opacity of the material.
You can even just pull in a specific channel, whether it's the green channel, the red channel,
the blue channel, to have an alphaed material as well, depends on what you packed into that
texture sheet to begin with. But suffice to say, there's a number of ways that we can
achieve creating a masked material. And it's up to your kind of preference and also just
workflow of how you're trying to pack textures together on the approach that you want. When
we're looking at a material setup that we want for thinking about masked materials,
we'll use the minus nodes and some clamps here as well. So we'll create or use a black
and white texture, which we provided in the project, and you can create a texture sample.
So a nice little shortcut here is if you do use the texture that was given in the project
or anything that's already in your content browser, you can have that selected in your
content browser. Don't double click it, you can just select it. You can come into the
material and if you press T on your keyboard and left click, it will first of all create
a texture sample, but it'll also automatically apply the texture that you had selected in
your content browser. So it's just a nice quicker way of working. Again, you could always
just press T or just right click, add a texture sample and then select the texture after the
fact. It doesn't matter either way, but it's just a little bit more streamlined way of
working. Next, we want to create a one minus if we need to flip the masking effect. So
this is our one minus and it'll essentially just flip to the opposite. So if you've got
Alfred on the outside and the solid colors on the inside, the one minus will then flip
it to translucent outside and opaque on the inside. So it'll just basically flip the effect
that you're going for, which you can see this one minus doing there. So instead of importing
a brand new texture that does the same thing, but in the opposite way, we can actually just
dial that in based on the material, which, you know, reduces the amount of texture samples
you might need in your project, which is really useful for having that flexibility. So we've
done this to make some kind of gold trim on the material. Next, we'll create a clamp to
keep things in range if parameters are introduced for control. So if someone programs into your
shader, they will see that they have a clamp to keep things in a nice certain range. So
that's just more of a quality control type of clamp that we've put in there to make sure
we're getting the desired effect. We can also use Lerp nodes, which is a linear interpolate.
So you can just right click, add Lerp. You'll likely see that it's called linear interpolate
as well. And so we'll create a Lerp node and run the one minus into the alpha input of
the Lerp. And then we want to duplicate that process for the material texture. So when
we talk about duplicating the process, you can actually select these nodes, Ctrl C to
copy, Ctrl V to paste, and just work a little bit more efficiently there. So you just want
to notice that there's not a metal texture for the wood. So we can plug in a constant
into the Lerp. So this is the setup that we're going for here. You can see that we've got
that const going into the A, we've got the texture sample going into the B, and where
the alpha is actually based on this texture sample here. And then when we talk about masking
textures for materials using one texture, you can actually see that we've got, if you
go into your texture and you click through the RGB channels, you'll see there's different
information packed into the various channels. And we can actually just pull off, say the
green pin or the red pin in this instance, to get specific information from that channel.
So if in your external app, you've either painted or included some information onto
a specific channel, instead of just using the main RGB channel, if you're layering stuff,
for example, in Photoshop, you can just pull off that information in the RGB channel, or
even the alpha channel, and use that. And so we call that texture packing. You can pack
multiple textures into one texture when importing it into Unreal. And it's just a slightly more
efficient way to work if you especially if you're trying to keep the texture sample instructions
down to a minimum. So go ahead and follow through those steps, you can create a mass
material, play around with the type of masking approach that you'd like. Again, we kind of
noted two or three different ways that you could create a mass material based on the
samples. And again, it's going to be project specific, depending on what you're trying
to achieve. But hopefully that gives a good overview to the mass materials. And also just
to add at the end of this that we want to credit to Frick for the scene shown in the
RGB channel. And then we've also got a documentation on how to mask materials if you'd like to
dig into that topic further.